Dear Fellow Scholars, we have just
reached 250 subscribers on the channel.
So far, the reception of these videos
have been overwhelmingly positive.
I'll show you some of these comments on the screen in the meantime.
250 subscribers. This is probably not much compared to
even mid-size YouTubers, but it means
so much to me. It means that there are
250 people, somewhere around the world
waiting for new videos to come up.
This is insane! If you think about it even one subscriber is insane.
Even one click from somewhere is mind-blowing!
Imagine that someone who you
have never met, somewhere on the face of earth.
Perhaps in Peru.
Somewhere in the United States or maybe in the middle of
Africa is excited for your work and just
waiting for you to say something.
There are millions of other videos they could
watch, but they devote their time to listening to you.
And now multiply this by 250.
I am just sitting here in disbelief.
As a computer engineer I've been working
with computers and network algorithms
for a long time but I still find this mind-blowing.
I can just record the
lectures that I hold at the University
and thousands of people can watch it at
any time, even while I'm asleep at night.
I can teach people while I am asleep at night!
We have over a thousand views on my
first lecture which is possibly more
people than I will ever reach through
the university seminar rows.
So for all 250 of you and everyone who
has ever watched any of these videos,
thank you very much for watching and subscribing.
I have created two minute
papers to show you the best of what
research can offer and what your
hard-earned tax money is spent on.
Because that's the thing: every single
country I've been to, researchers are
complaining about the lack of funding,
and rightfully so, because most of them
can't secure the funds to continue their work.
But let's try to turn the argument around.
Funding comes from your tax money,
and 99.9% of the case you have no idea what your
money's spent on. There are lots of
incredible works published every single
day of the year but the people don't
know anything about them.
No one is stepping up to explain what
your money is spent on, and I am sure that
people would be happy to spend more on
research if they know what they invest in.
Two Minute Papers is here to
celebrate the genius of the best and
most beautiful research results.
I will be trying my best to explain all of
these works so that everyone is able to
understand them.
It's not only for experts, it's
definitely for everyone, so thank you for
all of you
thanks for hanging in there and please,
spread the word. Let your friends know
about the show so even more of us can
marvel at these beautiful works.
And until then I'll see you next time!